a gun
over his shoulder and a kiss for a child
one of the key houthi rebel leaders
knows how to work a crowd
he and his armed guards are here to
rally the troops and remind the sparring
militant factions
who the real enemies are
death to america death to israel and the
west they're chanting
time and again the former head of the
houthi revolutionary council
urges the fighters to stay strong
the houthis have held out for five long
years
backed and funded by iran this
impoverished country is the pawn in the
middle of a proxy war
against a coalition headed by saudi
arabia and supported by britain
these people feel like they're taking on
some of the giants of the world
saudi arabia america even britain and
france and that's what's
uniting them all this suspicion and this
distrust
of those political powerhouses but the
rebels have been repeatedly accused by
the united
nations of committing war crimes too
there's a u.n report which says
that the houthis are recruiting children
as
soldiers is there any truth in this
the gun culture is strong here but he
denies forcing children into the
conflict
no no no these people you see all around
you
are they children the u.n
takes all their information from our
enemies
we've been given exclusive access to the
former houthi president
one of the commanders who helped the
rebels seize control of the yemeni
capital sana six years ago
he's now bent on accusing the coalition
of a litany of war crimes
and takes us to a bridge which he claims
has been bombed with the help of british
expertise
the british prime minister is aware of
all this he tells us
we drove hundreds of kilometers through
dry riverbeds
traversing remote and rocky mountain
trails
eventually climbing up the last few
hundred meters
to reach the isolated hillside village
community of washer
close to the saudi border we are the
first foreigners to reach here
the first outsiders to investigate this
attack and see what happened on the
ground
here an air strike wrought terrible
damage
reducing one home to rubble within
seconds
inside it was packed with women and
children from the majali family who were
gathering for lunch
nine people were killed instantly six of
them children
targeting civilian areas is an
international war crime
one of the neighbors holds up a baby's
bib pulled out of the debris
and leggings belonging to one of the
toddlers
there is household paraphernalia all
around solar panels a tv satellite dish
cooking equipment the attack shocked
this community
who've become so used to their cries of
injustice going unheard
of there were body parts
i've never seen anything like this
before
we found shrapnel from the bomb still
littering the site
and neighbors and relatives showed us
pictures they took immediately
afterwards
many of the dead children are too
graphic to show but there are also
photographs showing identifying marks on
the bomb
fragments we tracked other pictures
filmed soon after the attack by houthi
activists
and shrapnel collected by them it
appears to be the same
with the same markings weapons experts
we consulted told us the fragments found
here seem to be part of a
500-pound fin guided bomb manufactured
in america a coalition spokesman said
they were investigating whether this was
an
accidental loss of civilian life whilst
targeting houthi leaders and fighters
but this is a poor farming community no
adult men were amongst the dead or
injured
there were only three survivors from the
washer attack
and one of them is a baby we crisscross
the mountain paths again
and managed to track down all of them
the first fled to hajja city 130
kilometers away from washer
nora told us she was feeding her baby
boy when the missile
hit her two daughters were killed
somehow she and the baby survived
i was screaming for help i was in shock
she says the house was destroyed i was
searching for my daughter but she was
dead
then i saw my sister-in-law and she was
dead too i just picked up my son
and screamed for help the third survivor
is a young teenage boy who he traced to
his cousin's house on the outskirts of
sana
he has the scars but he can't remember
anything
his cousins can they pulled him out
barely alive and are still
traumatized by it
you only recognize his mother from her
torso
one of the small children from his face
it was his brother's son his arms were
cut off
and his sister-in-law she had no leg and
no arm and she was
totally burned he said he heard the
explosion
but whilst they were scrambling to find
survivors the same jets circled the area
for 15 minutes
terrifying them further
the largest independent human rights
group in yemen is compiling a dossier of
what they say
are war crimes on both sides they've
documented at least 500 coalition
attacks against schools
hospitals and other civilian areas and a
handful
directly linking british arms
manufacturers and suppliers to the
crimes
people who are in authority in uk and
could have stopped this uh from
happening that they they didn't
they should uh take their responsibility
and they should stand in front of court
right
next to the victims who were injured or
killed in this
the villages of russia have very little
but they want justice more than anything
and those responsible for these
atrocities held to account
alex crawford sky news in washer yemen